سنبدأ هجومنا خلال ساعات او ايام
قليلة. كييف تنتشي بهجومها
المضاد والروس يشمرون عن سواعدهم
ويعدون العدة. خدعة امريكية في
الاسلحة المقدمة لاوكرانيا وقوات
كييف تخترق الاراضي الروسية
مجددا. فكيف سيرد الكرملين هذه
المرة? واستراتيجية روسية جديدة
لحسم الحرب وصافرة الانذار
الاوكراني تصرخ مع اعلان قوات
كييب حالة التأهب القصوى. وبعد
اعلان طباخ بوتين الانسحاب فجأة
من باخموت الرد ياتي من قديروف
في السودان تتواصل الاشتباكات
والسعودية تعلن بدء الحوار
السوداني على اراضيها. فهل تنهي
الرياض حرب الخرطوم? بينما
واشنطن تحضر مائة زورق حربي
لمواجهة طهران. وبريطانيا تنصب
تشارلز ملكا في اكبر منذ سبعين
عاما ايران واسرائيل تتوددان
للسعودية فمن سيظفر بود المملكة
اذا الوضع وصل لمرحلة الخطر
العراق يستنجد بالمجتمع الدولي.
موسكو تحدث استراتيجية الهجوم.
كليب تشمر عن ساعدها وموسكو تغير
استراتيجيتها لتدخل الحرب
الروسية الاوكرانية مرحلة صعبة
لا رجعة وها هي السلطات الموالية
لروسيا تعلن انها تتوقع بدء
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد خلال
ايام او حتى ساعات. ليعلن القائم
باعمال حاكم مقاطعة زبروجيا
الموالي لروسيا افغيني باليتسكي
عن اجلاء سكان ثمانية عشرة منطقة
سكنية وبلدة بعيدا عن منازلهم.
والسبب هو تكثيف القوات
الاوكرانية القصف عليها حسب قوله
وفق وكالة تاز. من جانبها روسيا
كانت قد استبقت اي هجوم اوكراني
وذلك باستراتيجية جديدة غيرت من
طريقتها في الحرب الاوكرانية حيث
لجأت لترسانتها الحديثة من
المقاتلات الجوية ومنظومة دفاعها
الجوية المتطورة لاول مرة وفق
نيوز ويك لتستعر الحرب اكثر يا
سادة. فمن ذا يطفئها لتعلن
السلطات الاوكرانية حالة التأهب
الجوي في العاصمة كييف. مضيفة ان
صافرات دوت في المنطقة. نعم لم
يعد هناك اي مجال للعودة. فمفرمة
الحرب الروسية الاوكرانية قد
اعلنت عن خياراتها فان الانتصار
واما اعلان الخسارة. هنا وبعد ان
ظهر بجوار جثث جنوده يصرخ
بهستيريا بسبب نقص الذخيرة
مهاجما بشكل مباشر وزير الدفاع
سيرجي شويغو وقائد الاركان
فاليريك جراسيموف مستخدما سبابا
مباشرا لعدم امداد قواته
بالذخيرة المطلوبة. طباخ بوتين
يعلن الانسحاب من باخموت في
العاشر من الشهر الجاري. ليعلن
تسليم مواقعه لقوات الرئيس
الشيشاني رمضان قديروف ليتكفل
الاخير بمواصلة القتال وتحقيق
النجاح. اليكم المصدر. ياه! لقد
كتبت رسالة الى القائد الاعلى
للقوات المسلحة. مفادها اننا
مستعد لتولي مسئولية باخمود.
وسنكون سعداء للغاية بالاستيلاء
على الاراضي المتبقية هناك.
لدينا الموارد والوسائل لاستبدال
اي شخص لا يستطيع التعامل معها.
والجنود في حالة تأهب. نحن في
انتظار الامر. لقد تحركت عدة
وحدات نحو مناطق العملية
العسكرية. فهل يستطيع قاديروف
تحقيق نقلة نوعية في هجمات
القوات الروسية كما هو مع عنه
لتأتي الاجابة من العاصمة
الاوكرانية كييب. والتي اعتبرت
تهديد قائد فاجنر بالانسحاب من
باخموت خدعة لاكمال السيطرة على
المدينة بالتزامن مع الاحتفال
بيوم النصر. ها فمن يخدع من?
لينتقل الاوكران من الدفاع الى
الهجوم. وباستخدام سلاح الجو
الاوكراني تم اسقاط مسيرة تابعة
له فوق كييف وذلك بعدما فقد
السيطرة وكأنه يلطم خديه بيديه.
ولكن ليست كل الهجمات الاوكرانية
فاشلة. حيث تعرضت منشأة اليسك
النفطية جنوبي روسيا لهجوم ثان
بالمسيرات في غضون اربع وعشرين
ساعة لتفيد سلطات الطوارئ
الروسية في كريسمدار عن اندلاع
حريق في منشأة اليسك النفطي. فهل
من رد روسي قريب ومن حرب
المسيرات الى معارك اسقاط فقوات
اوكرانيا تقول انها اسقطت للمرة
الاولى صاروخ كنجل الروسي الذي
تفوق سرعته سرعة الصوت وذلك
باستخدام نظام باتريوت الامريكي
مهلا مهلا مهلا. هل هي حقيقة؟
للعلم امريكا بنفسها اعترفت انها
لا تستطيع صده، فكيف صده
الاوكران اليكم المصدر. بعد ان
وصفها الرئيس الروسي في وقت سابق
بالسلاح المثالي اعلنت القوات
نجاح نظام الدفاع الجوي باتريوت
باسقاط صاروخ روسي تفوق سرعته
سرعة الصوت. هنا اوليكريوتشكو
مستشار رئيس جمهورية القرم
الروسية يقول بانه مسقط صاروخين
باليستيين اوكرانيين فوق شبه
الجزيرة. وبين كل تلك الهجمات
تواجه اوكرانيا مأزقا عسكريا قبل
الهجوم المضاد حيث ذكرت صحيفة
جورنال الامريكية ان واشنطن تبحث
دعم الجوية الاوكرانية بمزيد من
الصواريخ لصد الهجمات الروسية
خاصة سلاح الطيران. وتأتي
المساعي الامريكية مع قرب نفاد
مخزون كييف من الصواريخ بسبب
تصديها للغارات الروسية. فماذا
لو نفذت تلك الصواريخ وللعلم
ستفقد اوكرانيا هذه المساعدات
الخارجية اذا فشلت في تحقيق
توقعات الولايات المتحدة خلال
الحرب ضد روسيا خصوصا في الهجوم
المضاد نحن من صرح بل صحيفة
النيويورك تايمز. اما الولايات
المتحدة فجعلت الامر يشتبه
علينا. فمن جهة تدعم كييف ومن
جهة لا ترغب بتحقيق انتصار
اوكراني حيث كتبت صحيفة جورنال
عن مسؤولين امريكيين قولهم ان
البنتاجون اجرى تعديلات سرية على
منظومة هايمورس بحيث لا يمكنها
اطلاق صواريخ بعيدة المدى. ومن
واشنطن ننتقي الى المانيا. حيث
يتم تنفيذ تدريبات لجنود
اوكرانيين على دبابات اللايو
بارك في ساحة تدريب عسكرية في
كليدز شرق المانيا جنبا الى جنب
مع هولندا والدنمارك. ونادت
تمكين الجنود الاوكرانيين من
تشغيلها وصيانتها بشكل فعال.
وحتى الان تم تدريب اكثر من
ثلاثة الاف جندي اوكراني في ارض
التدريب بكليدز. ومن المتوقع ان
يصل هذا العدد الى تسعة الاف
نهاية العام. ومن الحرب
الاوكرانية الى الازمة
الاوروبية. وبعد اهانة رئيسة
الحكومة الايطالية جورجيا ميلوني
من قبل وزير الداخلية الفرنسي
والتي اعتبرت ميلوني عاجزة عن حل
مشكلة الهجرة في بلادها. روما
تطالب بالاعتذار بينما دعت رئيسة
الوزراء الفرنسية اليزابيث بون
الى حوار هادئ مع روما بشأن ملف
الهجرة. بصيص امل سوداني المعارك
لا تنتهي والسودان يدخل في نفق
مظلم فهل الى حوار من سبيل وفي
بارقة امل جديدة طرف النزاع في
السودان يعلنان عن انطلاق
المحادثات في جدة بالسعودية.
وبرغم هذه المحادثات فان
الاشتباكات لم تتوقف على
الميدان. حيث شن الجيش غارات عدة
على مواقع لقوات الدعم السريع في
العاصمة السودانية الخرطوم.
وقالت مصادر سودانية ان عدة
اندلعت وسط الخرطوم وسط تبادل
للاتهامات بخرق الهدنة الجارية.
ومع استمرار الهجمات من الطرفين
انقطع الماء والكهرباء عن مناطق
واسعة بالبلاد ليعيش السودانيون
في عطش وظلام دامس فيالى قساوة
هذه الحرب يا سادة. لتستغل
واشنطن هذه الاوضاع في السودان
ويصدر الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
امرا بتحضير قائمة عقوبات اشخاص
ومن بينهم طرف النزاع بالسودان.
الاحداث والتطورات. افادت وكالة
بلومبرج بان الولايات المتحدة
تخطط لارسال اسلحة بقيمة خمسمائة
مليون دولار الى تايوان وفقا
لنفس المخطط العاجل المستخدم
لمساعدة اوكرانيا عسكريا.
الولايات المتحدة الامريكية تخطط
لنشر مائة زورق مسير اضافي في
بحر الخليج للقيام بدوريات في
مواجهة ايران بحسب بلومبرج ايضا.
شهدت بريطانيا تتويج تشارلز
الثالث ملكا للبلاد. في اكبر
احتفال رسمي تشهده البلاد منذ
سبعين عاما بعرض يتسم بالعظمة
والفخامة لمهرجان يعود تاريخه
الى الف عام. صرح مستشار الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي ساحي هنغبي
بان بلاده تأمل نجاح محاولاتها
العلاقات مع السعودية خلال زيارة
مستشار الامن القومي للبيت
الابيض جيك سوليفان للمملكة هذا
الاسبوع وفق سبوثنك. الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي ايران
والسعودية دولتان كبيرتان. وعودة
العلاقات بينهما ستغير المعادلات
في المنطقة وتنظمها. فالشعوب
المسلمة في المنطقة تتجه نحو دعم
المقاومة ودعم العدالة. لا نقبل
ان تعد سعودية عدوا لنا. شدد
رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
السوداني على ان انخفاض مناسيب
مياه نهري دجلة والفرات يستدعي
تدخلا دوليا عاجلا. مضيفا نحتج
فيه الى جهود جميع الاصدقاء
لمساعدة العراق في ضمان امنه
المائي ومستقبل اجياله. مع
اقتراب الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
لا شيء يلوح في الافق بقرب تحقيق
نصر اوكراني ومع روسيا
لاستراتيجية هجومها لا زالت
الاوضاع في اوكرانيا على حالها.
فهل يميل الطرفان الى الحوار?